he is a white supremacist he named his  oldest son adolph hitler  and he strolled into a new jersey  courthouse yesterday dressed in the full  nazi uniform to try to convince a judge  to allow him visitation rights with his  toddler named heinrich his toddler named  heinrich  he says prisoners get to see their  children murderers get to see their  children what's so horrible about being  a nazi  i just want to be a dad i just want to  prove i'm a good father because i am so  what if i'm a nazi who cares  campbell and his now estranged wife  deborah had their four children taken  away from them in 2010 because of  charges of violence in their uh in their  home we covered that story back in 2010  so our audience who's been with us for a  while might remember this family and  they showed up on authority's radar  after they publicly complained that a  local shoprite supermarket refused to  write seven-year-old son adolf hitler's  name on a cake